i've been enjoying the search for lore
and from soft games since before the
release of dark souls 3. this meant that
i was waiting and eager for eldon ring
and all the mysterious lore and hidden
revelations it was sure to bring i
analyzed trailers i covered live streams
and when the game came out i delved into
the story and the many threads that made
up not only it but its multiple endings
i was proud back in the day when i
released one of if not the first
breakdown of the endings of dark souls 3
and i was proud again to do something
similar for eldon ring and if you want
to support me making more content like
that feel free to subscribe to the
channel
that search for truth and meaning and
the scattered evidence of the game and
the chance to share those findings with
the community and really positively
interact with others who enjoyed it all
the same way was fantastic
i had that same feeling of discovery
with eldon ring and i still do but just
as we alter the cycle in eldon ring
things have felt a bit different in this
most recent iteration of the fromsoft
formula as fromsoft fans we are used to
mysteries and things shrouded in
uncertainty but in some ways eldon ring
feels like it takes things further there
is more left unknown and without any
comment at all the definite set of
events or timeline or relationships are
murkier and more up in the air
another youtuber ratatoskr even has a
video about how for him the lore of
eldon ring is quote uninterpretable
ratatoskr lays out his issues and
confusions well so i recommend you watch
his video if the topic piques your
interest while i don't think i come to
his same conclusions i am sympathetic to
the ideas and concerns the video talks
about while we have always had things
left up to interpretation in the past
there was always something definite to
base the interpretation on ratatoskr
points out that lots of the elden ring
world and timeline simply don't have
information or answers that we can then
use to interpret or glean themes from he
points to examples like the motivations
of queen america or the allegiances of
the black knife assassins and examples
have come up in my videos too
even my most recent videos on estelle
and the elden beast both end with
conclusions of uncertainty about each
creature i was able to say some things
about their likely origins and
motivations but i had to quickly move
into speculation to say anything of a
real note and because of that the videos
ended with well this may be the case
like the knox may have made the estelle
but i don't have any definite evidence
on the matter this seems likely but we
don't know for sure
ratatoskr also brings up how this lack
of clear events leads to a quagmire of
connections between things and people in
the game we saw a bit of this in my omen
and crucible video the crucible being
anne or the original form of life in the
lands between sets up well that it can
be connected to quite a few things as i
go over in the video we find traces of
it in the crucible knights the
misbegotten the omen and subsequently
the omen killers and even animals all
around the lands but then these things
get murky due to the connections that
these beings have with others we see
some connection from the dung eater and
his curse to the omen recall also that
the omen naturally have cursed blood and
the cursed blood also extends connection
from mo to the formless mother another
outer god that we get little information
on other than through connection with
moat do all of these beings now have
connection with the crucible 2. in that
video i also talked about the
similarities between the crucible as a
primordial form of coagulated life and
the frenzied flame ending which seems to
move in just that direction melting the
world back into one so do we then
connect the omen crucible knights and
misbegotten indirectly with the three
fingers shabiri bike and hayeta
now this could be a good time for a
counter along the lines of isn't it good
storytelling to have an interconnected
world where one thing branches to the
next and that to the next and so on and
to that i would have to say of course
that makes for a world that feels real
and lived-in and authentic but we still
have an issue because the boundaries of
these connections are so blurred the web
of life connecting all the players and
events in the lands between is out of
focus we can discern some of the ties
but we can only do so with a poor level
of clarity as the game just doesn't give
enough of the core building blocks to
properly or cohesively piece stuff
together or so the argument goes this is
acutely of concern for ratatoskr's aims
because he sees the basic whose whats
and hows as the boring stuff or the
stuff to first get clear on only as a
means to seeing a bigger picture focused
on themes and messages because we cannot
come to conclusions on the facts of the
matter and many things in game he
doesn't see how he can get to that
richer discussion of themes and
overarching ideas thus eldon ring is
uninterpretable we lack the tools to go
about interpreting it as his thumbnail
suggests
in making the point he also brings up
the ashes of ariandel dlc and dark souls
3 which in a discussion of themes is a
fantastic piece to touch on since it is
essentially a microcosm of the main
theme of dark souls 3 and maybe the
whole dark souls series feel free to see
his video for a more in-depth discussion
of it but succinctly the message of
ariendel is that of the response to
stagnation as things age and stagnate
the world rots and there are two
possible reactions to this rock we can
either try to endlessly prolong life and
the world as we know it suffering
through and bearing the effects of rot
and stagnation or we can let what we
know come to an end we can accept its
death and let a new age usher forth in
ariendel this new age is brought about
by the burning of the old world the fire
burns away the rot and a new world is
able to be created painted in this case
rise up beyond the ashes
the cyclical themes of dark souls are
captured well in this dlc ages of fire
and dark choosing to prolong the flame
or let it fade and begin something new
the negative effects of halloween and
endlessly prolonging the faded age all
of these themes are present in the games
and they are nicely captured in the
short experience of ariandel it seems
clear to me that these themes and
messages line up with the quote unquote
best ending in the base game of dark
souls 3 2.
yes fromsoft does leave the choice and
interpretation up to us the players but
their overarching themes in support of
self-determination and in condemnation
of stagnation of endlessly prolonging
that which should be allowed to end make
it seem pretty cut and dry to me that
the proper ending for dark souls 3 is to
let the fire fade
opting to do so with the help of the
fire keeper allows the ushering in of a
new age free of any remnants or power
grasping by the player or the followers
of koth it cleanly captures the overall
ideas and themes of dark souls 3 with a
player choice
coming back to eldon ring i could say
that this example should make us look to
a potential dlc to answer our questions
and i will do that i mean i do hope that
we get a dlc that fleshes things out but
i'll give such an answer with a very big
caveat
the dlc won't get rid of the issue with
the base game unless it includes some
retconning or something like that in
dark souls 3 we could come to a
conclusion about the themes and choose
the ending which corresponded best to
that conclusion and we could do all of
this without needing any guidance from
any dlc the dlc just acted as a
reinforcement or retelling of what we
already were told this is not the case
with eldon ring while we may be able to
get more clarity from a dlc the base
game itself does not support a similar
conclusion making process
when it comes to the endings of eldon
ring i feel less confident that i can
say for certain how one rises above the
others in gelling with the themes of the
game of course i still do say so just
with less confidence ronnie's ending
really does seem to me to be the best
encapsulation of player choice but i can
only defend that viewpoint with
arguments and evidence up to a limited
threshold in this game more than any
previous one i feel less able to say
that the correct ending is not just a
matter of preference and i see more
people favoring different endings in
this game than in dark souls 3. editing
mad here with a possible correction i
ran some polls in my community and
people seem to be in more agreement
about the elden ring ending the age of
stars being a canon ending than they do
with dark souls 3 endings so maybe i'm
mistaken and the ending for elden ring
is actually more of a consensus than the
previous games obviously this could just
be a bias of what i've been exposed to
but through my discussions with other
content creators the greater level of
unclearness seems to be something we
agree on even if the degree to which it
matters may be up in the air so we may
be in a less clear position now but does
that mean that we have to wait until dlc
comes out to make any kind of conclusion
or can we come to some kind of
understanding about what themes and
ideas are central to the game right now
as someone who is continuing to make
these videos my answer will probably be
unsurprising yes i think we can make
some worthwhile conclusions and find
some meaningful answers in the search
on one level all of this confusion and
unclarity can constitute a message
itself this is something i really picked
up on in talking to another creator
crunchy who makes great in-depth lore
videos make sure to go check out him and
his recent video on what elden ring
means if any of this stuff is enjoyable
to you the whole context of the elden
ring being shattered can justify the
hodgepodge of events and timelines that
we find the elden ring helped constitute
the order of the world and with that
broken the logic of the world is broken
too we as players take up the role of
choosing what to do with the ring in the
ending we choose we can mend it a
certain way bring in ronnie or burn
everything with the chaos flame as the
logic of the game world is broken we as
players are the ones to set it right as
such it is up to our choices and our own
sense to make sense of the story and the
events we find in game
and in crunchy's words
ultimately the game is about the player
deciding how they think the world should
be ordered as a player your beliefs
about elden ring decide how the elden
ring in game is repaired from software
has put the story making in our hands as
players somewhat similar to what they
did with halloween and dark souls making
it dependent on whether the player
themselves seeks to continue to push
through the game or give up and go
hollow thereby letting their player
character go hollow too but even past
this larger player narrative of choosing
what to make of the world we do still
have some level of certainty about
in-game messaging and thematic choice
through what the game does give us we
can learn about things like the frenzied
flame for example we come to understand
its motivations even if its origin and
specific implications are still murky
and in terms of conclusions i think we
can find justification to reject it
based on the themes of the game which
emphasize and extol striving despite
struggling finding beauty and hardship
and never choosing to give up basically
everything the opposite of what the
frenzied flame and tribury say the game
even gives us melanot to reiterate these
themes when we are deciding if we should
make the choice obviously the player can
still choose the flame just to see the
ending and many of us do or did but in
determining what the right course of
action would be and what should be canon
if anything what we think of as canon
the themes are present in game which
make a pretty clear delineation that
does not support the frenzied flame
ending as best or right at least i'm
pretty confident of that now we can
still say that the intense ambiguity in
this and especially other things which
we know even less about like the black
knight assassins for instance do take
away from the overall richness of the
experience and story things are just a
bit off with so little known about so
many of the events and the characters
especially characters who act in game
and who we interact with like melanoma
and even ronnie to some degree but of
course the loris lutheian is pushing
ever forward there are soldiers like
smoketown v-limit crunchy and more on
the hunt for lore and producing videos
on really novel stuff you can find them
and other creators on the hunt at the
round table hold section on my channel
page there is definitely more research
and discovery still to be had but the
issues that ratatoskr brings up are
meaningful at least i would say they are
and they do present somewhat of a
problem to confront in this hunt for
lore this search for meaning and to not
be too repetitive with a point from my
previous videos this seems like another
area that shows some limiting of the
game scope could have been helpful
instead of cut content and dialogue
random repeat story bosses and a massive
world that leaves quite a bit just not
fleshed out a slightly smaller game with
more concrete core events and evidence
for the player to find would have given
a stronger sense of lore and a better
ability for us to piece things together
that in turn would have led the player
to being able to get a bit clearer on
the subsequent themes and whatnot while
still leaving the door open for plenty
of weird occult or tangential things to
stay mysterious
more clarity on the black knife
assassins who are featured presently in
the game and actually do things in the
game wouldn't mean that the ancient
structures and time of crumbling feram
azula can't still be mysterious and
archaic and full of unknowns lost to
time leave the time before the urge tree
shrouded in mystery but give us more
information on the happenings of the
shattering and the night of the black
knives let us wonder about the broken
structures and barely unearthed ruins
throughout the lands between but fill us
in about the wars of the shattering and
the actions of the demigods there's a
balance to be struck and even with from
software's penchant for mystery in mind
it feels like eldon ring lands too much
on the side of the player left in the
dark
but even with all of this we might be
running into the same problem that i am
talking about in game i would bet that
more than a few responses to this video
will be that eldon ring is properly
mysterious just like every fromsoft game
and every game has cut content and
dialogue in quests and that this is no
different just like with the endings to
some degree it may come down to each
person's preference and how they
interpret things to determine if they
think this is an issue for the game so
let's just turn it back to you the
watcher do you think the lore of eldon
ring is uninterpretable like ratatoskr
said it was for him or is it right for
many more years of hour-long smotown
lore videos are these two questions even
in opposition but the answer to both of
them be yes can we reach the themes and
bigger picture despite lacking
resolution in the details let me know
what you think i've tried to touch on
both views in this video and since i'm
likely to keep making content especially
an upcoming video on the themes of the
game and how they connect to other
things like philosophy and berserk i'm
more in the camp of recognizing issues
but still thinking that there are
workable themes which we can grapple
with player choice struggling
self-determination and affirmation of
life stand out as a few of them
if you would like to aid that continued
search for lore and meaning you can
support the channel by subscribing or
becoming a patron on patreon your
support helps me dedicate more time to
the channel and videos
also check out those i mentioned in this
video and linked to in the round table
hold if you are looking for more lore
content they all make really good stuff
with that i will thank you for watching
and hope to see you in the next video
thanks bye